bonjour linda linda maintenant c'est le
moment des enfants oui un moment que je
chéris particulièrement linda il faut à
nous dire concupiscence concupiscent
déjà j'aime invités de marque
aujourd'hui l'invité d'une droiture
exceptionnel un chanteur que la famille
particulièrement dénommé serge
gainsbourg
bonjour serge tout va bien je suis
content que de jeunes talents sa
présence en chine
et maintenant tout de suite nous avons
cette marque
les enfants c'est pas conclure c'est pas
ton tour laissé le micro
bonjour commandite a fait qu des dames m
comment tu t'appelles l'a bien dit mais
la d8 ouais ouais tu vas à l'école la
limite nous tu fais un sport tas
d'ennemis oui qu'est ce que tu fais
comme ça vient brusque j'ai pas nous
montrer ce qu'il sait faire c'est bien
la lumière merci le dire qu'est ce que
tu vas nous chanter de serge 15 basso on
écoute en altitude
la balade est inadéquat je suis brune
ptg qui j'avais connu non c'est pas
votre bonjour monsieur comment tu
t'appelles caroline et on en sait quoi
et derna lié à sup est en fait une
croupe
il est là bas la salle naïve paul van
haver la wii à bas l outil peu l'enfant
là bas mon papa il est pas mal non
on voudrait pas payet n'était pas là
mais où l ont titouan ne l'est pas
bonjour
bonjour bonjour comme habitat fait bip
viennent taper un nom
on aurait voulu taper et même quelques
questions de faire manger à la maison de
nous sinon que de nous
je voudrais pas manger des faits non
c'est pas des fêtes c'est sûr habiter
nous nous sommes régalés face au oui
d'avoir plein de copines nous faut des
copies l'étape 1 oui raconte comment il
s'appelle ciao
mais moi je ne fais jamais choqué
nationale sur les t-shirts que tu
cautionnes et celui qu'a fait un bisou
c'est toi dans ton papa d'amélie
j'ai simplement au oui tout bas tu voi
le mec avec le costume saumon avec la
gourmette en or et qui sent bon et ben
c'est le gros qui bavent à côté d'un
moment sa maman c'est la date qui à côté
du nom c'est pas ma maman maman c'est le
nom du coach zahoui
on va la rentée coup eu ma petite iq est
100 de ma braguette jpy si je perds mon
temps si kate n'ont été aussi gaz à tous
les étages
en plus notre oui d'accord c'est 15 07
oui aussi maintenons cependant aux
médecines 36 que l'as tu as tu vas être
pourquoi pas il est dans la salle ta
maman si c'est pas un peu bêta par la
casbah 10 dons commandites ap homogène y
a c'est un joli présent ça dure
m la commandite à madame son billet 03
39 ans et ça fait de mieux expliquer que
ce n'est pas pour cette émission aussi
venus voter pour un croyant même